good morning hickets tuesday i'm wearing
a suit which can only mean one thing
it's time to talk about money today's
video is like the power of the dog
except with much less oscar buzz it
comes to you in five parts part one tick
tock hank did you know it's possible to
make a tick tock let people see it for
like 12 minutes and then private it it's
the best way to use tick tock and yes i
realize i have just invented snapchat
but what a great invention anyway will
anyone ever see the 120 tick tocks i
have privated shortly after uploading in
the last couple months including the
bobsled one and the hot tub one i don't
know in unrelated news there will be so
many wonderful perks available to donors
during the 15th project for awesome our
community's annual 48-hour charity
fundraiser which begins february 25th at
noon eastern time did i just say the
15th project for awesome goodness part 2
money so in 2021 vlogbrothers earned
just over 145 dollars most of that came
from youtube ad revenue but some of it
came from youtube premium subscribers or
from super chats so where did that money
go half was donated to our project with
partners in health aimed at radically
reducing maternal mortality in sierra
leone the other half was evenly split
between a fund that supports educational
projects at complexly and a fund that
supports emerging educational creators
online so this year we are able to give
grants to educational creators like tom
lum and alexis nicole in flipping
physics you can find links to all the
educational grant winners in the
doobly-doo they're all great we've
organized vlogbrothers ad revenue this
way for several years but i want to be
clear that we're only able to do this
because hank and i have other jobs
mostly writing books for me and for hank
having 10 000 jobs including writing
books and those books would not sell as
well if it weren't for vlogbrothers so
it's not accurate to say that we don't
keep any of the value created by
vlogbrothers only that we don't keep any
of the ad revenue so that's the answer
to the clickbait title now let's get
back to the bank of nerdfighteria's
semi-annual report with part three the
matching fund every year a group of
nerdfighters bands together with hank
and me to create a matching fund so that
money raised during the project for
awesome gets matched and that is a big
reason why we were able to raise over
2.3 million dollars for charity last
year and if you can join the matching
fund this year by donating 500 or more
to the 2022 project for awesome that
would be amazing there is a google link
in the doobly-doo below thank you and
yes donations are tax-deductible in the
u.s it's like any other charity except
that it's called the foundation to
decrease world suck
i mean we maybe should have rethought
the name but here we are part four how
the p4a works so i should note that the
project for awesome is completely
separate from our community's project
with partners in health sierra leone to
radically reduce maternal mortality they
are different things so during the first
half of the ph4a we raise money for
pre-selected charities this year
partners in health and save the children
two organizations we've worked with for
many many years but we don't raise money
for a particular project we raise
so-called unrestricted funds so the
charities can spend the money wherever
they see a need and then during the
second half of the project for awesome
we raise unrestricted funds for
charities chosen by you through your
project for awesome videos and your
votes at project4awesome.com
we do this so that people who want to
give to charities they know and know
well can donate during the first half
and people who want to give to charities
chosen by our community can do so in the
second half part five videos i really
hope that you yes you person watching
this will make a project for awesome
video in support of a charity you care
about making such a video can help
people learn about organizations doing
good in the world and also if your
organization is selected for a grant
they could get quite a lot of money like
last year the project for awesome
donated over 27 000
to each of these charities chosen by the
community so i hope you will consider
making a video in support of a
non-profit organization you care about
and then submitting it at
projectforawesome.com before february
23rd there is a link to learn more in
the doobly-doo i am so excited for the
15th project for awesome hank i'll see
you on friday